based on what elon musk is saying to
elizabeth warren he's earned my trust oh
my i don't know i don't know if i would
take the computer implant from elon musk
but the story's still pretty funny elon
musk feuds with elizabeth warren over
billionaire taxes senator karen
all right billionaire elon musk fired
back at comments from senator elizabeth
warren on tuesday telling her to stop
projecting and calling her senator karen
i'll just show you exactly what happened
here's on twitter elizabeth warren says
she posts the boston globe elon musk
named times person of the year she said
let's change the rigged tax code so the
person of the year will actually pay
taxes and stop free loading of everyone
else elon musk said among other things
and if you opened your eyes for two
seconds you would realize i will pay
more taxes than any american in history
this year and elon is correct
the the establishment left with like
faux progressives like warren are able
to convince these progressives to to
believe this stuff just by saying it's
the craziest thing to me that they go
did you know elon musk's elon musk and
amazon paid no taxes and i'm like that's
insanely not true there's like it is
objectively false
it makes no sense on its face why would
you believe that
because they said it elizabeth warren
says it and it gets repeated
it's just not the case um yeah what's
the story with that with when they say
apple paid no corporate taxes this year
is that because their their costs
outweighed their their expenditures
outweigh their
it's usually a manipulation because one
thing you always have to pay taxes on
with like employment tax property tax
you've got local taxes state taxes now
federally or even at the state level
they might say you know we invested x we
worked at a deal with the city for a tax
incentive to put money somewhere and so
quite literally what could happen is the
city goes to apple and says tell you
what if you spend
you know
500 million dollars
building a factory here with x amount of
jobs
then we'll consider an investment for
tax purposes and and and you know give
you a tax benefit of x and then it's
like okay
so the government cuts a deal in
exchange for an economic
incentive with with the company and then
the left comes out and says but they're
not paying taxes it's like but they're
doing what the government asked them to
do
so imagine if they came out and said no
government i won't do anything you say
and the government would then be like
okay pay taxes and they'd be like okay
and not only that whenever they say this
they always use weasel words to make it
seem like elon musk pays no taxes elon
musk i i believe is correct when he says
he pays more taxes than any american in
history huh because he's gonna like he's
selling off all his property that's huge
that's gonna dramatically reduce his tax
bill but his tax bill was probably
insanely huge just off of owning things
and so basically this is all about the
stupid wealth tax which makes no sense
where they're like we're gonna tax
people for cash on things that aren't
liquid
which is the dumbest idea ever like you
could have this gorilla right here and
then one day someone's like that's a
rare gorilla it's worth a million
dollars and then all of a sudden i'm
supposed to pay you a million dollars
because i have a plastic gorilla on my
desk that makes no sense yeah the the
0.0001
native american senator karen also
really hates cryptocurrencies in bitcoin
and has called for a lot of regulation a
lot of government intervention and an
extremely high tax rate for people using
cryptocurrencies and bitcoin so there's
a big divide between
elizabeth warren and of course elon musk
and elon musk has been on a tear lately
he's been making a lot of bold big
statements specifically saying that he
doesn't want to build back better bill
he thinks that bill should be absolutely
shunned away he thinks that the united
states government is just a major
corporation that has a monopoly of
violence he's been speaking out against
a lot of core issues including vax
mandates saying that absolutely there
shouldn't be any vax mandates and it's
really interesting to see his talking
points and
and i think you know a lot of times
people are are changed politically
especially when they look at the taxes
that they have to pay well out of their
paycheck so i think you know most
definitely elon musk
saw that the taxes he had to pay and
that kind of changed him politically
being like this is pissing me off i'm
going to first voice my opinions since
i'm giving so much money to these people
and these these multinational
corporations it's very interesting when
you do research into them
these bills these tax increase bills
potential tax freeze and bills are going
to screw over small businesses mid-sized
businesses because multinational
corporations i mean i've been covering
pfizer for quite some time now they can
offshore their profits and build the
headquarters in ireland and say you know
we made 50 billion dollars in ireland
we're not paying we're paying 2 in taxes
this year because all of our profits are
in ireland if you're a mom-and-pop shop
that
generates like a gross revenue of a
million dollars
there's no way you're going to be able
to offshore any of your profits so the
these bills senator warren is is a total
fraud if you notice that when she talks
about oh we're going to go after wall
street she never names a firm on wall
street that she's going to go after
because she's in their pocket and there
for some reason there it's interesting
with elon musk you know he's kind of
becoming based now and he's on the
really bad side of the biden
administration to the point where they
had a big electric vehicle meeting at
the white house and how to craft that
bill and they did not invite tesla
that's like not inviting uh you know
sony to the future of video games
conference it's just very bizarre
i want to explain something to to people
about taxes that uh a lot of these
progressives don't understand do you
think that you know bezos cares about
his tax rate
he does not
he's probably like i got too much money
man i don't even know i don't even know
when he gets his paycheck because bezos
gets eighty three thousand eighty one
thousand dollars a year sorry it's his
salary and then he gets incentives which
ultimate like bonuses he ultimately
comes out to about 1.6 million he
probably looks at it goes oh
because how much money do you really
need to get by
so bezos has his stock he has his assets
he has tons of money but at the end of
the day he gets his paycheck and he
probably says
i don't even look at it he probably just
ignores it outright because it's
meaningless
now a poor person i remember my it was
like my third job i was working for an
airline out of o'hare airport
and i'd worked 40 hours at 10 bucks an
hour and so i was like all right so it's
going to be what it's going to it's like
that's 400 bucks and then i got to pay
taxes so i imagine maybe i'll end up
with you know 300 to 350 we'll see what
happens and my paycheck was like 2 270
something and then i got my paycheck and
i looked at it and i just was like i
just was like what up
and then all the older guys where they
started laughing and they're like he saw
the taxes didn't he
and then i was like dude i'm poor i
can't afford to live
like working 40 hours at 10 bucks an
hour and then being told that
almost half of the money i'm making was
like 28 or whatever it's taken from me i
needed those hours i needed that money i
couldn't afford rent i couldn't afford
my car i couldn't afford health care but
when you're rich and they go we're going
to take you've got your salary is 10
million dollars we're taking half you go
i don't know so what's my paycheck this
this this month
488 000 whatever deposit it i'm sitting
on assets i don't care i don't even
notice so these tax increases are not
gonna are negligible to a lot of these
people well a lot of the super rich have
called for more tax increases because it
makes sure that they stay on top and
their competition doesn't have an
opportunity to have enough income to be
able to compete with them so you know
these people want higher taxes because
it actually benefits them they want more
regulations they want a higher minimum
wage because at the end of the day it's
destroying small mom-and-pop businesses
while of course it's benefiting them
greatly and they have other ways they
have so many different incentives
whether it's setting up offshore
corporations and then selling off the
intellectual property towards a domestic
company here in the united states
there's so many different rules there's
a reason the tax code is as big as it is
because there's a lot of exemptions for
a lot of powerful people that helped
write it that works in their favor that
obviously screws everyone else who would
be competition to those people exactly
this big this builds back better bill
that they're promote promoting in
congress and that uh joe biden's all
about and all those people are all about
this was crafted by the lobbyists for
the giant corporations it's by and for
these giant corporations it is not to uh
you know help our economic engine it as
luke said it's to seal off the
competition from these oligarchs that's
that's the entire purpose of it it's
it's this state corporate enterprise
they want to they want to phase out all
types of
possible competition
yeah i was just thinking about taxes man
yeah just i'm just like
i'm going through the numbers and it's
interesting that
i'm imagining
back when i was younger and trying to
calculate budget how many hours this
week do i have to work to get by and how
how taxes really brutalize you when
you're making just enough to be above
poverty or whatever they take taxes out
anyway and it's like if you if you got
to pay 500 bucks a month in rent and you
can only work 40 hours a week like
you're going to be struggling to make
ends meet if you've got rent food health
insurance whatever you want the bare
minimum then any amount of taxes taken
out is is gutting you
dude to be told that
you know you're going to lose uh 230 you
know effectively like 23 hours of the
work you did that week or 20 hours of
the of of the work you did that week
it's like why even do it if you're
working that much to have it taken away
from you maybe maybe it's unfair to say
that much maybe it's like you know 13
hours or whatever
the point is
for people who are extremely well off
you could tell you could you could tell
that ultra rich person were taking 90
and they'd be like i don't know i don't
care about my income anyway because
everything's in hard assets and
everything's accruing in value so what
does it even mean to me it's in property
it's in stocks and but this is this is
the problem then when that when they say
they want to raise taxes across the
board i mean even bernie sanders plan i
think would have still raised taxes for
like middle class and upper middle class
people and what i try to explain to a
lot of people uh at occupy wall street
for instance and and other leftist
activists
what we need in my opinion
is more tax brackets not just to be like
after you make 250 000 we tax you at
this percentage because somebody who
makes 250 000 being taxed you know
48 or whatever or 38 i think it is then
they end up getting take home about 100
or so thousand dollars but somebody
who's making 10 million dollars who's
taxed the same rate
doesn't notice a difference when they're
having millions of dollars deposited in
their account i have a little bit of a
different perspective i think there
should be no taxes and if the government
wants to launch any project they have to
do it through gofundme and they have to
have enough public support and private
charity to do so i think that would be a
more rational way to do this than of
course steal people's money yeah i like
that for some except for like utilities
about like water the water supply and
the power supply
the military if you look at most power
supply companies especially in
california it is riddled with corruption
you look at venezuela and their kind of
energy companies when when they were of
course brought into the state government
it absolutely ruined venezuela the
infrastructure hasn't been updated the
government has no incentive in order to
provide you any quality of service the
private market does and that's why i
would argue the government getting
involved makes the situation that much
worse
what about the water supply because if
the water supply goes haywire the
government well it depends on like what
aspect and what variability you're
you're discussing like are we talking
about sanitation are we talking about
sanitation and cleaning
yeah who's gonna take my poop from my
house that's right luke and you're in
your and your ron paul and kappa stand
paradise where's poop go you could
there's literally companies out there
that are developing technology that
makes poop into it's true energy
and and and power so so the private
market would be again way better i'm not
saying it's going to be a perfect system
obviously with any system there's going
to be some kind of harm there's going to
be some kind of idiot that ruins it for
everyone else but i think overall there
would be a lot less harm a lot more
economic prosperity a lot more freedom
just like we saw in singapore just like
we saw a few years ago in hong kong
civilization
bro they execute you if they find you
now now they do but but singapore
became known on the world stage as a
free economic market where a lot of
people fled to and it was able to build
a society that that was a free market
society that allowed private enterprise
to thrive and it created some of the
most richest people um in the world now
obviously has devolved into a full
technocratic state with a social credit
score with surveillance cameras watching
your every move if you spit on the
ground or if you chew gum the wrong way
i thought
i was sweating bullets in in singapore
uh with tim because of uh a disgruntled
tinder date was was saying
that that she was gonna call the police
on me for not going on they got her you
got catfish oh it was bad it was a
horrible i luckily was able to kind of
see it and then we had to like escape
out the back door whatever was funny i
was laughing the whole time yeah uh
luckily i made it out but i was sweating
bullets um apart what was happening
there it's a crazy way that they decided
to live their lives but anywhere you see
the free market kind of activated you
see a lot of individual freedom you see
a lot of liberty you see a lot of
services that are incentivized to help
the person rather than a government that
will take your money and then doesn't
need to provide you a good service what
if uh what if we created like a special
economic zone in the united states yeah
that was like totally you know free
market we had two different ones one was
for the commies and one was for the
endcaps and you could choose which one
you wanted to go live in perfect that
would be absolutely beautiful one city
is dedicated to the communists and once
you're once you choose to live there you
can't choose not to and then the free
marketplace you can come and go as you
please exactly and then if if you know
commies want to live in their own
commune go ahead um
i won't be mad about it would you no t
tim you're a cold weather guy right what
about greenland biggest property over
there
yeah i know and trump wanted to buy it
and i was like that sounds great yeah
and they made fun of him for it it's so
weird because like it wasn't even that
long ago we bought alaska you know i
mean
exactly and it would provide so much you
know
opportunities uh it would provide a lot
of expansion it would provide
you know potentially an economic free
zone which i think would be amazing and
if you look at the history of those they
always turn out into incredible things
you look at the history of government
top-down centralization controlling
every aspect of the financial
institutions you see communism and you
see
uh people starving and not having food
people being slaughtered it's sent to
the gulags and i think there's a big
overall trend when it comes to economic
freedom and political freedom we need
star link
we need um
we need low latency high-speed satellite
internet then then you can live and work
from anywhere and that's what i'm
excited for because
we we've been looking at you know we're
in west virginia we're setting up this
big 50 acre property but we're still out
here
because we have to be close to a major
airport or whatever and so that will
tether us in our operation you know
closer to you know bigger cities but you
could go to a smaller regional airport
someone could fly to a major airport
then to the smaller airport and then you
could effectively have a a media
operation in the middle of wyoming in
the middle of nowhere so long as you
have that satellite and that low latency
communication star or greenland and
decentralized service server space
that's once we get starlink and like
maybe satellite server space too orbital
server space i think we're going to be i
think the future the future of this
planet is going to be people spreading
out outside of cities and then wiring
themselves into the into the metaverse
and living digital virtual lives could
you imagine just like if if your entire
life
was the matrix but it wasn't like the
movie the matrix you knew you were in
the matrix so basically you'd like wake
up in the morning and you you'd brush
your teeth then you'd go into your pod
you know that stimulates your muscles so
you don't atrophy and then you enter
the digital space and then you're you're
in green land you know doing your work
and you're like i got a meeting in new
zealand and then so then you just walk
up to a door and you you type you know
you activate it uh new zealand please
the door opens right open and you walk
right to new zealand because you're in a
virtual world dude it'll be like i'll be
in my house you'll be in your house but
we'll both be in this studio digitally
it'll look like it that we're both
sitting next to each other and we'll be
seeing each other you can do that now
and the video will look like we're all
in the room together well yeah because
you'll be we'll be wired in the matrix
but here's the thing so we're all
kind of against it now but because
if we're talking about this future
technology in the sense that they can
like kind of like regulate your dopamine
we will all become addicted to the
metabolism that's the problem it's not
even about that it's not going to be
it's not going to be that tomorrow you
know elon musk knocks on your door and
then like you know he's holding the chip
and then two guys in white coats pin you
down and you're like
it's gonna be that they're gonna roll
out the the the neural cap it's a hat
you wear that can you know um
alert you when you're when your phone
goes off or something like that or
google s it's going to be some small
convenience we accept and then every day
the convenience is going to escalate
think about how cell phones started
big big gray block you pulled the
antenna up it had like four hours of
power only worked downtown and they
sucked and then i remember when you know
my mom had a cell phone it was like
roaming charges and connections and it
like worked it was better it was like a
gray motorola you'd flip it down then i
got my first candy bar phone these
phones didn't do anything but it was
convenient to have you could talk to
people or beepers for instance now we
have the summation of the access to the
summation of human knowledge in our
pockets we can film videos it is
escalating
everyone accepts it they're okay with
being tracked they're okay with being
spied on because of the convenience so
neural link will happen whatever all
this medivar stuff will happen no one
will resist it we are going to accept it
and be happy about it how many people if
you went back in time
and said i'm gonna take away your
landline phone and you will be happy
they'd be like no i wouldn't i need my
phone be like no no don't worry we're
gonna give you a tracking device that
people can track everywhere you go no
matter where you go and it'll spy on you
but you'll be able to talk to people
they'll be like screw that are you nuts
no give me my phone back
that's not that's not where we're at now
is it so i'm watching the chat room and
someone just left a comment saying
imagine this chat but in vr and i'm like
oh
that would be wild i'm seeing what you
guys are saying here it's
crazy it already exists
there's on oculus there's i don't know
what's called it's like live chat and
i'm i brought the duck thing in that
little kid because i was playing the
game i was playing space robot trainer
that pirate game that's so fun you're
like you got robots and you're like
you're shooting at them and then i went
to the chat room and it's like people
walking around and there was a duck just
like walking around doing stuff and i'm
like someone literally went in this game
and said i'd like to be a duck and they
did the the graphics are trash mind you
because the processing power isn't all
that great or whatever but imagine what
it's going to be like when they
synchronize neuralink how long is that
going to be 10 years 20 years
maybe maybe maybe that's a bad estimate
maybe 30 or 40. oh it could be still
much sooner than that i know
look out look look at look at 1986 1981
the video games that were out mario
brothers
30 years look where video games ended up
you you've got
first person 3d now look where we are
it's been almost 40 years it's been over
40 years and look how rapidly video game
technology has advanced to the point
where now we got vr glasses you with
with the new oculus you put it on and
there's no wires you can go out in your
backyard and set your space and then
just do whatever in virtual reality
wireless yup i keep thinking about the
chip did you guys see the video the
chimp on instagram
let's just look it up someday i don't
know if you want to bring it up now it's
it's kind of a non-sequitur it's a
little what about this it's just a
chimpanzee on instagram he's on
instagram swiping and he's like it looks
like a human like this is oh this right
here yeah this is nuts is this there we
go
i mean we are he's just he's animals
he's watching videos of chimps doing
chimp stuff yeah
you see sell their chimps
well yeah but chimps are smart monkeys
you know monkeys are smart too
we'll be we'll be in the metaphors with
these guys
look at that he's swiping he's looking
for stuff he just he hits it and he's
like yo what up that may help us
understand other animals a lot better
because if we can wire them knows how to
do it like if you could neural net and
synchronize with an ape and then you can
kind of understand the animal
more i don't know man and it could
understand you more i think i think
everything that we're saying is going to
be viewed in the future as like stodgy
old people
complaining when we laughed at remember
that guy
i don't know if you know this ian
there's a guy who uh who was it was it
it was it was someone famous he said the
internet wouldn't take off oh robert
reich wasn't it was it i think so is
that krugman it was crazy
and he was like the internet will not be
part of the economy or something like
this
he likened it to a fax machine he said
it would be as big a deal as a fax
machine i think that was the quote
let's see what he did krugman say the
internet's effect on the world economy
would be no greater than the facts
machines true
look at that man this guy is still today
a very dumb nobel prize winning
economist that's right wow about
everything
but think about it man people back then
i remember watching you know i watched
these old videos that come up where
they're like no the internet's not going
to take off well certainly an
interesting novelty it won't be and then
you get krugman you got people like it
watching these old videos about the
internet it's crazy yeah because it is
life today well you know even with cell
phones and the advent of social media i
would say it was a net positive in the
very beginning because it was unfiltered
uncontrolled there was no major
algorithms it was what you subscribe to
is what you get and there was a moment
in time where people finally started to
get the true window to the reality of
the world that wasn't controlled by any
kind of special interest
now those doors are closing and i s and
i'm seeing social media as a net
negative especially with the
psychological disorders that it has
caused so many young people causing
people to of course be so unhappy but
the larger debate that i think should be
sparked here is it because we have too
much knowledge that has gone into our
brain too fast is the ability to be able
to know anything in a moment something
that is detrimental to human society or
human beings a power that they never had
before that's an interesting kind of
debate that i've been kind of listening
and hearing about that i think is worth
talking about in 50 years people are all
born
and they're implanted with their neural
chip
and they grow up
and they live mostly in the metaverse
and there's a young man he meets a young
woman and they're getting along
swimmingly and they're all excited and
then they're like you know oh i've gotta
i've gotta move pods um
you know oh i'll come help you move your
pod and then the guy's like that that'd
be great yeah they're coming to move the
pod to unit c39 over you know about a
block from my house it's gonna be a lot
of work it's gonna be annoying and then
you know one day there's a knock on the
door and it's like a six foot three
really burly bearded man and he's like
rick good to see you and he's like janet
and they hug and they kiss and then they
carry the pot out to the new unit then
they go back in their pods and you know
the big bearded guy is actually a five
foot seven blonde woman in the metaverse
like i'm not even kidding like it's
gonna be normal and people are gonna be
like whatever because their reality the
reality is going to be the metaverse and
the real world base reality is going to
be a chore it's going to be ancillary
it's going to be like something they
have to deal with
it's going to hurt
it's right gravity hurts yup it's going
to be like you know when you're like in
a pool and when you get out you're like
oh man like no no cold it's like all of
a sudden like when you're under when
you're in the water you can move much
more easily and then when you lift up
you're like whoa i'm heavy now and
you've got all this water holding you
down that's what it's going to feel like
people are going to live that way it's
like in the movie surrogates where
there's that hot blonde woman and then
like the machine blows her head up they
go to the apartment and it turns out
it's this morbidly obese guy who's in
the machine like hooking up with kids
there's something to that in the age of
gender fluidity where like you can be
any gender and you can pick your avatar
kind of i mean it totally synergizes
with what you're saying yeah yeah what
do you think what's the future gonna
look like in a few years from now so
from a technological aspect um you know
you have the famous moore's law but what
you find so i think this might be a
problem of our progeny i don't know i'm
not convinced it's gonna happen so fast
because technological innovation in the
electronic space is actually slowing
down there's only
so you have a circuit board and there's
only so many transistors that you can
pack on there so it's probably going to
take something like a neuralink
technology you know totally flip the
board over start working on like brain
electrodes because in terms of like
improvement of technology the idea it is
no longer exponential and it hasn't been
for for quite some time it's actually
eventually going to flatten out because
this this circuit board technology
it's already like
done by robots and microscopic there's
literally like no more room for these
electrons
the transistors have transistors have
become so small that electrons aren't
even falling on the path they're jumping
off and moving between things they're
using sound now as a wave guide to mu to
force the electrons along the path so
they don't actually have to use i don't
want to get this wrong i don't know more
about it but they're using sound to
guide the light yeah so with a neural
link if you're doing brain surgery then
who knows where this takes off but if
you're trying to use like your oculus to
expand into the metaverse i don't see it
as being something so similar to human
life through that platform
but again when you're when you're
dealing with the brain who knows what
could happen so what if in the future we
stopped making you know
computer chips and we started growing
brain matter and then you're like dude
the new uh ryzen threadripper
5000
organic and it's just like a brain in a
vat and it's got like ports and
everything we start having cone heads
just like in them in the hollywood
movies and because that there's also we
are using we're using our own brains as
our desktops is what you're saying no no
no just like in in the conehead movie
their brains just like start expanding
upwards
and there's also that wasn't in the
coneheads movie uh yes it was no they're
just aliens with coneheads exactly we
could become
they probably had bigger brains no
right they have bigger i don't know but
there's also a set of human beings that
are recorded uh with their skeletons
having cone heads that's it they were
doing elongation some people are
debating that but there's also some
other interesting theories by brian
forrester that uh contradict that theory
as well um i don't know what the truth
is but um if we're gonna be expanding
brains i'm pretty sure it's gonna be
conehead you know i was thinking about i
think what we should do is um now that
vax mandates are normal we should
actually just have a metaverse mandate
and then we should have to send the
government out to forcefully neurolink
chip people's brains and plug them plug
them in against their will because once
you connect them to metaverse and you
can control their thoughts you can take
away the pain and then they'll like it
perfect so all we have to do is chase
people down while chanting one of us one
of us perfect and they'll be scared at
first but as soon as you infect them
with the with the metaverse they'll
easily calm down and then join you in
your quest
to transform everyone else into a
singular being you know just like the
independent says we have to de-regulate
the uh radicalize the hardcore
anti-vaxxers uh and treat them like
terrorists you know
i don't know what that has to do with it
that's the independent it's all for the
greater good tim send them to the verse
in the name of health thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you